[Music]
better life gets messy kept Clorox
Disney Pixar's Incredibles to June 15th
dreaming of us super getaway closer then
get ready to enter the Incredibles to
big-city sweepstakes powered by Clorox
we'll send you to New York to drop in on
the coolest sights in the city will you
go to Times Square for a super shopping
spree at the Disney Store mr. incredible
not included to help with all those
shopping bags 25 first prize winners
will receive an Incredibles 2 Clorox
prize pack the great teen plus you can
enter online for free at Disney Tom
slash big city sweeps vortex big city 10
Disney message data rates apply no
purchase for super powers necessary and
you can check out Incredibles 2 in
theaters g-53 PG
[Music]
the mythic struggle superheroes
suit up it might get weird I'll be there
a step
[Music]
hey little baby Incredibles 2 PG tickets
available your new home has all the
latest security and automation features
what is that one water level sensors for
surprise attacks and overflowing
dishwashers motion sensors intrusion
detection so we'll know if someone's
sneaking in or sneaking out carbon
monoxide detection and of course smoke
alarms ADT helps you and your family
stay super safe see Disney Pixar's
Incredibles 2 June 15 even superheroes
need to feel safe darling so we're here
at Pixar where the artists are bringing
the movie to life I'm in super power yes
so what do we need to become super
ourselves well first I need to draw you
that way you don't throw stone he has
like that helmet maybe that could be
something yeah that's cool I've always
wanted to be able to shoot lasers oh and
I've always wanted to fly big wings
right you can fly over the city then
just like the last time yes now colors
bright blue with like some black and
purple stripes and I was thinking maybe
like purple with some yellow lightning
bolts Oh what if we both had the power
to spawn tastes like a bottle so we
could like like all the time what's your
name and what does that mean
means fire rockers okay time to suit up
Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 in theaters
June 15 rated PG
you